[Musique]
info intox avec à mes côtés anthony st
léger bonjour anthony et alors que la
russie on vient de le voir promet
l'ouverture de couloirs humanitaires des
vidéos des deux justement menée par la
russie circule sur les réseaux sociaux
oui on s'intéresse ce soir un reportage
d'une chaîne d'informations en continu
russe regard des détenus par le kremlin
elle s'appelle vesti en l'occurrence
vesti 92 parce que c'est l'antenne de
sébastopol en crimée alors qu'est ce
qu'on voit sur cette vidéo regardez on
voit des camions remplis de cartons qui
décharge de l'aide humanitaire des
personnes qui font la queue cette
distribution elle est menée par l'armée
russe ou et hong hong et place de la
libération à kherson cette ville du sud
donc à deux pas de la crimée on le
rappelle et c'est surtout la première
prise à des risques depuis douze jours
d'offensive
c'est ici pour ceux qui voudraient avoir
une localisation géographique leur
présence des russes à d'ailleurs été
dénoncée on le rappelle samedi dernier
et à dimanche dernier par des
manifestants dans les rues de cette
ville et quand a été tourné la scène en
question est bien le vendredi 4 mars et
distribution alimentaire et le lieu est
ce reportage lui a été publié le 6
comme dans tout reportage il y avait ce
qu'on entend et puisqu'on aurait pu
entendre effectivement on s'est arrêté
sur un extrait du reportage en question
va regarder et surtout écouter la
séquence si on en parle juste après
morgan
je ne sais pas s'il ya quelque chose qui
vous a interpellé ou pas faut tendre
l'oreille voilà alors on va revoir cette
même séquence mais vous allez voir cette
fois il ya un indice
[Musique]
vous avez les mêmes pistes exactement à
raphaël quand on analyse la piste audio
du reportage et sa grâce au travail il
faut mentionner de pauline tchoubaïs et
d'arthur damas des observateurs de
france 24 on a pu en fait découvrir que
ce même son il est répété trois fois à
l'identique et cette répétition parfaite
elle n'est évidemment pas innocente
anodines elles montrent que le son a été
corrigé semble-t-il pour dissimuler
quelque chose et alors c'est le cas il
ya volonté de dissimulation ont très
vraisemblablement parce que le bruit le
sont corrigés masquer un bruit et ce
bruit c'est celui regarder des
manifestants qui sont en face d'eux
c'est un camion de l'autre côté de la
place c'est ce que nous montre plusieurs
vidéos alors là on est sur une photos
instagram et c'est ce que montre aussi
des vidéos sur twitter facebook ou
encore télégramme des manifestants qui
dénoncent cette distribution et plus
généralement d'ailleurs la présence
russe au nom 2 aux cris de plus tôt
pourquoi vendez-vous l'ukraine ou encore
vous mourrez de faim ces vidéos les
différentes qu'on a pu voir elle nous
offre en fait est un angle beaucoup plus
large de la scène elles ont été
vérifiées par les observateurs de france
24 et on peut donc en avoir le contexte
le parlement régional par exemple dont
on voyait ici le
l'édifice tout simplement on peut le
revoir aussi sur les vidéos en question
si j'avance un petit peu voilà bon alors
c'est de devoir dans ce pays voilà on le
voit ici sur cette vidéo il y avait
aussi par exemple sept personnes venues
chercher de l'aide humanitaire que l'on
voit dans le reportage on la retrouve
ici aussi que l'on voit ici en violet on
la retrouve voilà c'est un peu plus
clair ici devant le camion en question
donc ça on a pu repérer et aboutir à la
conclusion qu'on était bien sur cette
même place de la libération à carson un
vendredi mais les vivres les vidéos
aussi elles nous montrent autre chose à
savoir que les
les comédiens les manifestants de
l'autre côté de la place ont aussi été
empêchés d'accéder à cette distribution
de alors attendez que je le montre ici
j'ai un petit soucis voilà je me perds
dans mes pages on va y arriver voilà la
page en question en fait les
manifestants de l'autre côté de la place
ont été empêchés par les soldats que
vous voyez ici d'accéder juste justement
à cette distribution dead et les
observateurs de france 24 ont contacté
une habitante deux personnes elle
explique que l'entrée de produits et de
médicaments est entièrement bloquée pour
accéder à la ville et elle affirme elle
aussi qu'aucun habitant de cette ville
n'a pu avoir accès à cette aide
humanitaire et selon elle que les hommes
enfin que les différentes personnes
venaient de crime et on le rappelle
annexé en 2014 il faut préciser
toutefois que ses dires n'ont pas pu
être vérifiées pour leur part nos
sources merci anthony saint léger info
intox qui démonte un les fausses
informations autour de cette guerre